guillaume et françois noël vont vous
présenter le le programme
la plupart de nos intervenants lors de
la table ronde qui va commencer dans une
dizaine de minutes sont présents et puis
je pense que l'assistance au fur et à
mesure du temps va évidemment venir à
cette première journée des républicains
sur la politique de l'immigration
nous avons choisi de régulièrement venir
devant devant une partie de militants
devant les élus du mouvement dans le
bureau politique la commission exécutive
enfin le cadre du mouvement venir faire
le point sur l'état de nos réflexions
dans le domaine des sujets les plus
importants nous commencions évidemment
par la politique de l'immigration c'est
un sujet particulièrement dans
l'actualité dramatiquement dans
l'actualité c'est aussi un sujet en
dehors de l'actualité qui se pose
constamment régulièrement un autre à
notre pays comme à beaucoup d'autres
pays notamment européens
ce sujet nous l'avons inscrit au
programme des républicains au moins 2 au
mois de juin
comme nous avons inscrit d'ailleurs le
sujet du code du travail de l'évolution
puissante du code du travail que nous
traiterons le 30 septembre
bien avant les vacances donc nous ne
sommes pas aujourd'hui au fond sous la
pression d'une actualité c'est un sujet
qu'on a toujours considéré comme
prioritaire si au fond pour répondre aux
questions qui sont posées notamment que
les journalistes posaient à l'entrée
donc ce sujet c'est un sujet constant de
vigilance et de proposition n'a pas dé
des républicains nous avons mis en place
un groupe de travail c'est une méthode
conduit maintenant à peu près
constamment sur tous les sujets un
groupe de travail qui a travaillé sur le
fond composée d'élus d'experts qui a
travaillé tout l'été et qui aboutit à un
document d'orientation et c'est ce
document que nous allons discuter
ensemble au cours d'un certain nombre de
tableaux et une méthode
et cette méthode nous y tenons beaucoup
avec isabelle le callennec qui est comme
moi est en charge d'animer l'ensemble du
projet pour notre
mouvement c'est une méthode qui est
faite de travail de fond on peut pas
travailler sans approfondir les sujets
les pas question de rester à la
superficie des choses c'est également
des groupes de travail qui entendent
évidemment des experts ou des
personnalités de l'extérieur donc il ya
un travail d' écoute et puis un travail
de débats ce travail de débat c'est
celui que nous aurons aujourd'hui sur la
base de propositions précises et pas
uniquement évidemment sur l'air du temps
sur des propositions précises
et puis un travail comme l'a voulu
nicolas sarkozy de d'interrogation de
consultation de nos militants ce travail
débutera après évidemment cette réunion
en fonction des conclusions de cette de
cette de cette réunion donc cette
méthode elle vaudra pour tous les sujets
il elle nous amènera à terme au moment
venu
et au moment voulu et au moment
nécessaire à avoir bien évidemment un
projet pour les républicains qui peut
penser qu'un parti politique comme l'est
républicain n'est pas de projets c'est
évidemment quelque chose d'absolument
majeure et ce projet s'il socle commun
qui réunira d'une certaine façon celles
et ceux qui à un moment donné
s'affronteront amicalement ou pas dans
le cadre des des primaires mais nous
tenons beaucoup à ce projet nous tenons
beaucoup à l'idée d'un projet et d'un
projet qui réforme profondément notre
pays tout en respectant bien évidemment
les caractéristiques de notre de notre
de notre pays on aura le temps d'en
parler dans les mois qui viennent donc
le prochain rendez vous sur le code du
travail et puis après on parlera
d'économies et puis non évidemment les
élections régionales
revenons à notre sujet la politique
d'immigration l'idée c'est de traiter le
sujet mais pas uniquement sous l'angle
pression migratoire ou la pression
migratoire que connaissent aujourd'hui
les pays d'europe d'une crise une crise
sans précédente une crise tout à fait
gigantesque elle va être évidemment au
coeur des débats qui sont ce matin mais
d'avoir quand même une vision globale
panoramique total de la politique
d'immigration c'est bien ce dont manque
le gouvernement n'y a pas aujourd'hui
une vision globale de la politique
d'immigration il ya des prises de
position d'ailleurs qui changent de jour
en jour qui évolue régulièrement et des
contradictions les des volte face et
puis en même temps il n'y a pas de
vision générale c'est vrai d'ailleurs
entre nous pour absolument tous les
sujets mais c'est vrai particulièrement
sur ce sujet qui est probablement l'un
des plus
dramatique qui ait eu à affronter les
pays d'europe depuis bien bien longtemps
pour en parler
guillaume larrivé françois noël buffet
avec également roger karoutchi ont
organisé ce débat ont permis d'aboutir à
un certain nombre de conclusions discuté
au sein de de la direction de des
républicains et qui vont vous être
soumis et discuter en trois tables
rondes qui l'ont immédiatement vous
proposer à partir de à partir de 11h
nicolas sarkozy nous nous rejoindra
j'espère que d'autres nous rejoindront
aussi ici c'est table ouverte
évidemment le principe c'est les
républicains chacun chez soi chacun
vient débattre
chacun vient donner son opinion je note
d'ailleurs que les opinions sur les
sujets ne sont pas aussi différentes que
je veux bien le lire parfois dans la
presse je lis et des options parfois ddd
sensibilité enfin globalement quand même
sur la politique de l'immigration je
note qu'il ya une convergence très
fortes comme d'ailleurs dans le domaine
économique
il y a une grande convergence c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs pour ça que nous
sommes dans le même parti politique les
deux amis serge et peut-être pour ça
qu'on est exactement la même carte de
parti politique donc nous verrons au
travers de trois tables rondes nos
propositions vous verrez comment nos ce
qui interviendront les aborde la fin
nicolas sarkozy évidemment comme
président du mouvement conclura cette
journée et les conclusions définitives
après synthèse seront soumises aux
militants à l'ensemble des militants du
mouvement au fond les ténors ou les
sopranos du mouvement se sont d'abord
les militants
voilà bah écoute est bonne bonne matinée
alors si ce n'est qu'une matinée en
réalité on avait prévu une journée
complète ce n'est qu'une matinée parce
que le gouvernement a décidé avec le
sens du calendrier du timing de
d'inscrire au parlement cet après-midi
un débat sur la politique migratoire et
sur le problème des migrants il avait
déjà fait sur un autre sujet il ya peu
de temps
bon bah voilà le gouvernement court
après les républicains c'est je pense
une bonne nouvelle mais en tout cas
c'est un fait